This sharing is not just
with health providers.
Patient engagement is the key strategy
for preventing and managing diseases.
Patients in 2010 survey by
the California Health Foundation
reported that access to their
data improved their care.
Those using a specific tool,
a personal health record,
reported they knew more
about their health.
They asked their physician a question
they would not otherwise have asked.
They felt more connected
to their physician.
And they actually did something
to improve their health.
However, the survey also showed
that patient adoption is still low
with only 1 in 14 having used a PHR.
And adopters are predominantly young,
highly educated, higher income patients.
A big part of the reason seems to be
patient concerns about privacy and
security of their health data.
68% of the respondents
said they are very or
somewhat concerned about misuse
of their digital health data.
Keep in mind that PHRs
are cloud-based web tools.
So, it's likely that any well
publicized problems with data misuse on
the Internet translates into increased
patient concerns about health data
being stored there.
At least partially as a result,
a 2012 survey showed that
only 26% of patients want
their medical records to
be digital, with 85% expressing
privacy and security concerns.